[Musique]
la France est un carrefour pour des
millions d'oiseaux migrateurs ils
traversent notre pays et ils font
Escal depuis des millénaires ils volent
au-dessus de nos têtes mais depuis peu
leur nombre diminue et certaines espèces
même désertent no
ciel
[Musique]
pourquoi
je m'appelle Christian Moulec j'étudie
et observe les oiseaux depuis plus de 20
ans j'ai appris à piloter un ULM pour
pouvoir voler avec eux un rêve que je
partage aujourd'hui avec tous ceux qui
veulent
[Musique]
s'émerveiller
qu'est-ce qui a pu décourager tant de
migrateurs à venir chez
nous les villes qui s'agrandissent les
prairies qui
disparaissent y a-t-il encore d'autres
raisons j'ai voulu comprendre et agir
tout faire pour offrir aux oiseaux une
chance de continuer leur pélerinage
saisonnier du nord au sud de l'Europe
pour cela j'ai imaginé un projet un peu
fou une sorte d'école de la
migration partir avec un petit groupe d'
sauvage découvrir les pièges et les
dangers de notre monde moderne et
inventer avec elle une nouvelle façon de
voyager à travers la France t qu'elle
est puis remettre mes oiseaux en liberté
sur un site protégévec esoir que mes
élèves gardent les leçons du voyage et
puissent un jour les transmettre aux
autres oies
sauvages venez suivez-moi sur les routes
secrètes des oiseaux
migrateurs ça y est je vole avec mes
oiseaux
nous sommes en août et c'est le moment
que j'ai choisi pour démarrer notre
grand
[Musique]
voyage nous partirons de la plaine
d'Alsace empruntant le chemin des
cones puis nous passerons des forêts
desvuges à l'Auvergne de la Loire
jusqu'au Grand Marais de l'Atlantique
paradis des
[Musique]
migrateurs mais j'oubliaé les
présentation voici donc mes huit jeunes
oies toutes des oies cendré l'espèce la
plus familière de nos
campagnes les cinq frères et sœurs au
bec jaune sont de la branche scandinave
et les trois sœurs au bec rose de la
branche
sibérienne me voici donc à la tête d'une
famille recomposé doigt de souche
sauvage tout tené ce printemps mais en
couveuse chez
[Musique]
moi comment suis-je devenu leur père
adoptif d'abord je vis jour et nuit à
côté des ufs à qui je fais entendre ma
voix jusqu'au moment de l'éclosion et
cette voix avec mon visage que les
oiseaux
reconnaissent me voilà il y a 20 ans
apprenons comment faire les oies
s'identifient à celui qui est à leur
côté durant les premières heures de leur
existence même si c'est un
homme pendant de longues semaines je
vais renforcer ce
lien la même méthode a servi pour mes
oies d'aujourd'hui et si elles sont si
familières de l'ULM c'est parce que je
leur ai appris à trottiner Volter puis
voler à ses
[Musique]
côtés voilà pourquoi elles me suivent
aujourd'hui sans
[Musique]
difficulté à l'état sauvage les oies
cendrés migre du nord de l'Europe
jusqu'au sud de l'Espagne pour passer
l'hiver dans la nature elles apprennent
la route de la migration en suivant
leurs parents au voyage
aller au retour elles se débrouill
souvent
seul je vole à la lumière rasante du
matin ainsi le paysage se dessine net
château clocher village
rivière autant de points de repère pour
mes élèves migrateurs qui gravent dans
leur mémoire la route grâce à leur vue
fois plus précise que la mienne
elle calculle leur position par rapport
aux étoiles et au soleil et sont doté de
cellules sensibles au champ magnétique
terrestre un compas dans l'œil et un GPS
dans le bec
elles sont super équipé et pourtant
c'est moi qu'elles
suivent
il fait chaud le bec ouvert la langue
qui capte la moindre parcelle
d'humidité autant de signes qui ne
trompe pas elles ont
soif en dessous de nous une gravière
étrangement turquoise d'instin une noix
sauvage ne s'y poserait
pas c'est l'occasion d'une première
leçon
drôle d'endroit pour une
baignade d'ailleurs mes oies hésitent à
plonger dans cette eau couleur
[Musique]
Caraïbe
allez
[Musique]
allez ici rien de sauvage et pourtant
c'est un endroit
[Musique]
sûr en apprivoisant leur méfiance mes
oies ont gagné une nouvelle halte
migratoire savoir profiter de ce que les
hommes ont fait de la nature voilà la
morale de
l'après-midi nous volons depuis le
matin la fin tenaille maintenant maises
encore peu habitué à de longs
vol dans la nature elle se régale de
jeunes pous her tendre de graines mais
autour de nous pas une prairie des
champs cultivés à perte de
vue dans bien des régions c'est ainsi
rien n se mettre sous le
[Musique]
PEC alors je décide de me poser près
d'un champ de maïs pour une seconde
leçon profiteer des
moissons
grain feuille
épis un resto 3 étoiles pour oiseau
[Musique]
affamé bien téméraire la plus petite des
bec roses se faufile à l'intérieur des
rang de
maïs
tout en la gardant à l'œil je la laisse
faire la migration c'est aussi l'école
de la vie ou la prudence ça s
prend
de justesse une bonne
leçon les restes des moissons sont une
auine pour les migrateurs quelques
paysans l'ont compris et laissent leur
champ en chôe quelques semaines avant de
la
[Musique]
bourrerzz ontis en profiter le ventre
plein nous quittons la plaine
d'Alsace cap sur le massif des
vauges allez Allez
venez allez Allez
venez au-dessus de la forêt les oies
serrent l'ULM au plus près
elles savent d'instinct que cet océan
d'arbres qui défile sous leurs pattes ne
leur offre aucune prairie d'atterrissage
assez vaste pour réaliser une approche
prudente et redécoller si besoin en cas
de
danger je décide de nous poser sur ce
lac de barrage encaissé bordé d'arbres
et dont l'eau noire impressionne les
oiseaux
[Musique]
pour ce premier long vol de leur vie mes
oies ont dû puiser dans leur réservve
leur nuit passera à piocher dans l'eau
des algues pour se nourrir et à
boire boire une eau dont elles
mémoriseront à vie le goût comme on
garde l'adresse d'une bonne auberge pour
y revenir un
[Musique]
jour nous sommes en Auvergne au pied du
puit
Marie
comme à chaque nouveau paysage que nous
survolons la conversation s'anime car ça
discute beaucoup chez les
oies des cris de contact pour se
localiser entre elles et éviter les
carambolages car elles ne peuvent
tourner la tête en arrière pour
s'observer c'est aussi une façon de
savoir si tout le monde est là ell
reconnaissent parfaitement le cri de
chacune
elles attendent de moi que je participe
aussi à ces
conversationszz je fais de mon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mieux les oies de tête ont repéré bien
avant moi cette tourbière attirante en
contrebat on pourrait dire qu'une
migration d'IE sauvage c'est un peu le
de France des lacs et des étants tant
l'eau leur est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vitale
[Musique]
une fois posé je dois le reconnaître
l'endroit est
parfait un renard ou un rapace prédateur
naturel des oies il serait repéré de
loin quant aux occupants du moment ils
paraissent bien inoffensifs
quand on est
O la première chose qu'on fait en
arrivant quelque part est de s'imprégner
du décor qui nous
entoure après l'effort et le stress d'un
vol la baignade est aussi une récréation
nécessaire
et puis c'est plein de bonnes choses
larve insectes racines arraché à la
vase
[Musique]
je suis émerveillé de ce qu'elles savent
faire sans l'avoir jamais ni vu ni
appris de personne c'est inné entretenir
20000 plumes pas seulement un plumage
une machine à voler fuselage aileron
gouvernaille
propulseur du bout de leur bec elle
prélève un peu de cire d'une glande
situé sous leur croupion qui rend leur
plumage imperméable flexible résistant
au parasit
un défaut dans le plumage et c'est la
fatigue qui s'accumule en
vol de vrais
contorsionniste ça j'aurais jamais pu le
[Musique]
renseigner
j'observe la petite bec rose qui
m'intrigue un peu effronté elle
s'éloigne de ses frèes et
sur curieuse gourmande
ou
inconsciente l'herbe est plus verte
ailleur c'est bien
connu coup tendu à la verticale le grand
j n'est pas content il
oiseau isolé atre les prédateurs et met
tout le monde en danger
elle pétine sur place elle est inquiète
je n'interviens pas
exprès finalement c'est l'aîné des becc
rose qui prend l'initiative ramener la
petite à la raison et au
[Musique]
berkaaille
coup qui s'allonge et se balance on se
salue rentrer avant qu'il ne soit trop
[Musique]
tard
l'incident est clot mais entre les becs
roses et les becs jaunes une fellure est
apparue il ne faut pas attendre
longtemps pour que le groupe s'offre une
petite explication doigt
[Musique]
à les bec jaunes prennent vite le dessus
les voilà dominant au bec rose de filet
doux
dans tout groupe familial une hiérarchie
doit s'installer elle rassure tout le
[Musique]
monde ren de tel qu'une séance de câlin
pour resserrer les liens
familiaux je suis toujours ému de cet
attachement que mes oies me manifestent
depuis
l'enfance voilà bien bien bien moi aussi
je me suis attaché à
elle je devrais pourtant les quitter à
la fin du
voyage le ce soir mes oies ont des
fourmis dans les ailes c'est une pulsion
irrépressible elles sont jeunes il faut
que ça bouge il faut que ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vole
en cette fin de journée d'été les
courants chauds et froids brassent l'air
de la vallée j'en profite adul elles
auront besoin d'affronter des coups de
vent des orages turbulen vous voulez du
sport les
enfants ce soir c'est le son de
vol
si l'air était visible dans cette vallée
il serait comme un océan agité de vague
s'écrasant au pied des falaises
s'abattant sur mes oies et ma
[Musique]
machine et voilà les rafales qui
arrive mentalement je n'arrête pas de
les compter 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 il en manque une
[Musique]
le groupe se disloque mes o Val
d'uneelle à l'autre par-dessous
par-dessus en perdre une ne prendrait
que quelques
secondes chercherait à nous retrouver
volant jusqu'à l'épuisement puis
finirait par
abandonner seule elle n'aurait aucune
chance de
survivre c'est mon
[Musique]
cauchemar
à partir d'une certaine altitude les
turbulences
[Musique]
cessent l'air nous porte comme un
courant puissant calme et fluide
elles doivent le comprendre pour le jour
où elles auront à franchir seul de plus
hautes
montagnes
du bout de leurs longues plumes externes
les
rémiges chaque oiseau apprend à palper
le moindre souffle pour en épouser la
forme mieux que voler elle
[Musique]
surf
fini les becs rose les bec
jaunes juste une
famille le ciel est à
[Musique]
nous
septembre un mauvais brouillard nous
clou au sol ce
matin impossible de voler toujours la
peur de se perdre les oies se
[Musique]
serrent seulle la petite bec rose comme
à son habitude explore les
environs dans un groupe d'IE il y
toujours un individu plus curieux que
les autres et cela est souvent
profitable au
groupe je la laisse faire sans la
quitter des
[Musique]
yeux ah
puis soudain tout s'enchaîne le soleil
qui perce le brouillard le grand jar qui
surprend tout le monde et devance mon
signal de
départ il faut que je les
rattrape la petite curieuse est
[Musique]
surprise dans la nature elle n'aurait
que peu de chance de recoller au
groupe
je force l'escadrille à voler près de la
surface pour rester visible aux yeux de
la
[Musique]
petite in extrémis elle rejoint le
groupe les bec rose ser la petite sœur
de
[Musique]
près
cette leçon de prudence accidentelle lui
aura été profitable je
[Musique]
l'espère nous quittons le lac les
montagne et
[Musique]
l'auverne nouvelle journée nouveau
programme la
Loire depuis des millénaires les oiseaux
migrateurs suivent le cours des
fleuves ils y trouvent de quoi se
nourrir se poser se reposer une route
directe vers la mer une route qui ne
change
jamais les oiseaux de tête imprime un
rythme de croisière impressionnant 45
km/h à la
les plus puissants se relent et
consomment 20 % d'énergie de plus que
les autres qui se glissent dans leur
sillage et sont aspirés comme les
coureurs du Tour de France par le
[Musique]
Ploton nous cherchons les berges pour
nous poser mais avec les pluies
d'automne la Loire en cru a avalé ses
îles et rongé ses
[Musique]
rives le grand jar et la petite bec rose
rivalisent désormais d'attention et
mènent le
[Musique]
groupe
à la verticale de ce mur je m'aperçois
pourtant que nous nous battons contre le
vent notre vitesse au sol est quasi
nul mes oies s'épuisent pour rien et mon
moteur commence à
souffrir
dans la nature aucun migrateur ne serait
assez stupide pour insister il faut nous
poser quelque part vite et
bienation
[Musique]
bonjourcoup beaucoup de Turbul que je
peux poser sur votre
terrain
[Musique]
sur ce petit aéroport peu fréquenté je
ne risque pas grand-chose aussi je
profite d'être cloué au sol pour réviser
mon moteur et repartir dès que les
conditions le
[Musique]
permettent
allezz le poussez-vous là qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce bazard
allez
[Musique]
allez allez mais laisser cette petite
troupe d'adeau sans surveillance est une
erreuration l'uniforme est en dernier
virage 10s0
ok y aller n'est pas
[Musique]
finalement je compte que cette petite
frayeur leur sera
[Rires]
profitable
les aéroports offrent des espaces de
prairies trop tentant pour les migrateur
mais les oiseaux doivent apprendre à
s'en méfier chacun doit trouver ses
distances je dois me résoudre à y passer
la
nuit sécuriser le campement quand même
le renard attaque toujours la nuit
qu'ell s'envle dans l'obscurité et je
les perds toutes
le cri d'un renard les tient en
alerte comme toutes les nuits elles ne
dormiront que par brèv séquence de
quelques minutes et que d'un œil comme
moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au matin le vent est calmé mais le ciel
est bas l'ULM
tremppé l'épaisse couverture nuageuse
nous Gobrait comme des
mouches nous sommes
tankqués seul un petit décrassage local
est permis à mesoies
[Musique]
impatient allez
Balik adik adik adik એ
એ
[Musique]
pas d'étape aujourd'hui juste un vol de
reconnaissance
[Musique]
la petite intrépide et sa sœur
s'aventure là où le courant est puissant
comme un tapis roulant sous leurs pattes
et drive maintenant là où je n'aurais
pas souhaité les
[Musique]
voir au milieu du fleuve le piège est
tendu de vrais canards attaché par une
patte qui appelle les oiseaux de passage
et des faux canards qui font croire
qu'ici tout est
[Musique]
paisible et un affu de
chasseur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
videzz allez coup de chance
de mauvais
fusil vite il faut qu'elle
revienne j'espère que cette peur se
figera dans la mémoire de mes oies et
qu'ell seront éviter un piège semblable
ailleurs plus
tard la chasse fait partie de nos
traditions mais elle tue 17000 cendr sur
les 50000 qui tentent encore l'aventure
chaque année en France
allez allez
allezz
allez allez allez
allez une fenêtre météo donne le signal
du départ l'aîné des bec rose semble
graver le plan du site pour l'année
prochaine direction plain Ouest
les étapes se succèdent entre ciel gris
et ciel bleu entre campagne et ville ou
une autre espèce animale concurrente et
bien redoutable c'est installé depuis
longtemps l'homme il est
[Musique]
partout mais ces activités ne sont pas
toujours au
migrateur voici venue l'occasion d'une
nouvelle leçon
inattendue certaines autoroutes sont
devenues des repères de navigation pour
les oiseaux visibles de jour comme de
nuit moins signueux que les fleuves le
grand Jard et les becc roses surpris ne
cessent d'y jeter des coups
[Musique]
d'œils certaines espèces
se sont déjà abonnés à ces longs rubans
faciles à
[Musique]
suivre et en cas de fatigue les aires de
repos sont à disposition des 38 tonnes
oui mais ni chasse ni
[Musique]
dérangement les éoliennes ne sont pas
les meilleurs amis des oies par vent
contraire mauvaise visibilité elles ont
le réflexe de voler
bas surprise par ses épouvantails géant
PANI et leur groupe se dispers certaines
se
perdent je pourrais passer au large mais
je préfère flirter avec le danger
domestiquer le
[Musique]
peur
alle allez allez allezz attention les
éolien attentionz lesolien attention
allez allez
allez monte
monte tous les jours de nouvelles
éoliennes poussent comme des champignons
sur leur route
migratoire la prochaine fois peut-être
seront elles moins
[Musique]
surprises
octobre nous installe dans
l'automne jour après jour nous suivons
la Loire et ses plines
fertiles une vision ultra fine permet au
de différencier toutes les nuance du
verre et de choisir par instinct celui
qui correspond à la meilleure herbe
elle ne se trompe
jamais enfin
[Musique]
presque
mes bec rose ont attiré le groupe sur la
partie qui semble la plus délicieuse du
site le
[Musique]
green
cette fois-ci de leur familiarité avec
l'homme mes oiestirent
avantage je les y
encourage d'autres espèces pratiquent
déjà l'incruste
migratoire dans les parc ou jardin
public là où les hommes les prennent
pour des oiseaux d'ornement
ce signe de Bewick par exemple arrivé
probablement de Sibérie pour passer
l'hiver ici oou l'eau ne gèlera
[Musique]
pas allez
alle décidément les trois sœurs bec rose
font golf à
part la domination des bec jaunes sur la
frie tout comme mon autorité
paternelle commence à avoir du plom dans
l'
c'est normal elle
s'émancipe au fond de moi je trouve ça
bien comme
ça à l'heure de quitter les lieux un
oiseau s'invite à notre
équipage une canne isolée de ses
congénères sans doute et qui essaie de
trouver
compagnie j'ai souvent vu des oiseaux
intrus se mêler à des colonies d'une
autre
espèce tout sauf être seul et le mot
d'ordre des migrateurs capable
d'accueillir un oiseau qui ne parle pas
leur
[Musique]
langue
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui l'air est chargé d'un parfum
nouveau qu'ell hument
[Musique]
longuement je sais ce qui attend mes
oies mais pas
elle
[Musique]
enfin le voilà d'un coup le bleu infini
de l'Atlantique qui doit réveiller en
elle des millénaires de souvenirs
enfou car nous sommes arrivés sur une
étape essentielle du voyage des grands
migrateurs certains s'arrêtent
[Musique]
ici
la canne qui s'était fait oublier prend
les
commandes où se poser c'est son affaire
elle doit connaître le
[Musique]
terrain
tout est nouveau le sable les bruits les
odeurs la lumière le goût de l'eau
même
le fracas des vagues les
intrigues le grand jar reste au agé
fidèle à son caractère
prudent les becc Ros entraînés par la
petite curieuse partent à l'aventure et
échappent à son
regard et sur la plage les tentations
sont variées du meilleur comme au
pire faute de main elles usent du bec
elle mchon chaque prise pour en tester
le goût l'odeur la consistance de leur
pâte elle tambourine le sol espère en
faire surgir des
délices par milli les oiseaux meurent
d'ingérer par erreur nos tonnes de
déchets abandonnés sur les plages ou
rejetés par la
mer mais elles sont grandes je ne serai
pas derrière elle tout le temps elles
doivent apprendre d'elles-même à faire
la différence entre ce qui est bon et ne
l'est
pas le grand jar entend la canne mais ne
la voit
pas
perdue
à l'évidence il n'y a plus rien à faire
pour la sauver du danger qui la
frappe comment résister à un tel
malâ un tel costume bicolore
[Musique]
elle paradeun dernière fois avec sa
conquête nous ne la reverrons
plus mes oies aussi auront à trouver un
jour un partenaire qu'ell garderont pour
la
[Musique]
vie la marée monte le soleil décline
c'est l'heure magique de la
[Musique]
passer ce grand vol commun à tous les
migrateurs du monde qui qu le lit pour
se réfugier dans les Maré de
l'arrièrepays et y passer la nuit puis
au matin faire le chemin
inverse ce va et vient est une leçon de
vie essentielle pour mes oies qui
passeront ici de longs
[Musique]
mois
nous sommes un peu en avance mais déjà
quelques grues commencent à arriver
d'Europe du Nord dans quelques jours
arriveront les oies
[Applaudissements]
sauvages il me reste une dernière leçon
à enseigner à mes
protéger la plus difficile la plus
incertaine car le temps est venu où je
dois rendre à mes oies leur
liberté nous sommes à
Oléron dans cette réserve naturelle sans
chasse elles auront toute leur
chance mais il va leur falloir se
déshabituer de moi les becs jaunes déjà
distants les becs roses encore si
affectueuse maintenant je dois les
quitter
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en mélançant une dernière fois avec elle
je les imagine déjà se joindre aux oies
sauvages de passage
ici l'école de la migration les en a
rendu
capable capable d'apprendre des autres
oies bien des choses mais capable aussi
de leur transmettre ce que nous avons
découvert
[Musique]
ensemble
je les imagine traversant les montagnes
pour rejoindre leur terre
[Musique]
d'hivernage et je les vois un jour
enseigner à leur petits à leur tour les
routes de la
migration
[Musique]